this morning our series three meals
reveals what is on voters minds in
Virginia we went to Hampton
Fredericksburg and Alexandria for
breakfast lunch and dinner the state
once read has recently turned blue CBS
News contributor Steve Inskeep of NPR's
Morning Edition and up first drove
toward Washington DC where the president
was impeached last week Steve was that
the big subject the impeachment it was
only big for some people Dana much more
was on their minds as we heard starting
at Tommy's restaurant in Hampton
Virginia near the ocean Tommy's serves
troops from nearby bases nice to meet
you and five workers at a navy ship you
name it fear who had breakfast after the
night shift on nuclear aircraft yes
these men see a strong economy so strong
for Scott Siebert who supports President
Trump that he hardly cares about
impeachment I have not had a chance to
watch any of it he has a different
anxiety
what do you mean North I'm trying to
take bones I think second amendment
covers it I don't see where legally he
can do it we must do more than give our
thoughts and prayers governor Ralph
Northam wants a new democratic
legislature to strengthen gun laws after
a mass shooting in nearby Virginia Beach
partners carry a few feet from the
shipyard workers sandy and Leroy
shifflett days of danger are following
the impeachment it's not going to go
anywhere he's going to be removed from
office but you still think it's worth
impeaching it because he earned it
we're heading to a location that will
help remind us that the debate we heard
in Tommy's just now he's part of the
long-running debate over this country
that's gone on for centuries the battle
over impeachment that we've been
discussing as we travel as some of its
roots here in Colonial Williamsburg the
legislators in the old State Capitol
once included James Madison father of
the US Constitution an advocate of the
separation of powers including the
separation between Congress and the
president today that divided government
reflects a divided nation hi guys
including voters torn within themselves
as we learned at lunch in Fredericksburg
Virginia at the mason-dixon cafe well as
people know Fredericksburg on the
battlefield of work at this cafe which
serves breakfast all day Wow Tracy and
Dan Fischer recall voting in 2016 at the
voting station and person says Luke's
amis these that I'm rather largely
pregnant and says oh do you want one
ballot or two and wicker then I could
stop it coming out of my mouth I said
well I guess it depends on who I'm
voting for
on whether or not this person deserves
right that remark focused her mind on
what she calls her passion for the
unborn Tracy and Dan both voted for
Donald Trump somebody watching this is
gonna understand what you're saying
about standing up for people who don't
have a voice but then they're gonna say
what about migrant children what about
kids separated from their parents that
is an area I've been one of our as a
family greatest disappointments has been
to watch people taken at the border and
split up I'm proud to be an American but
America is not the only country and our
job should be to be a beacon of hope and
light to the people around us the
Fisher's say they still cannot vote for
a Democrat who favors abortion rights
but they see another moral choice
withholding a vote from the president
I'm not voting I'm having not to vote
in this heavy traffic we're now
traveling into the heavily populated
northern counties of Virginia the
suburbs of Washington DC which have made
Virginia far more diverse and more
democratic our destination for dinner is
an Indian restaurant called Domino owner
Raj Shilla game is an immigrant from
Nepal are you a citizen now yes I am the
citizen since like a 2016 he now owns
two restaurants and employs more than 20
people he got here through a visa
program the diversity lottery which the
president has wanted to end I didn't
like it we need a lot of people to work
here also this region's diversity makes
it vibrant though it also makes some
diners anxious it's almost become like
sin to say anything that like is not
seen as politically politically correct
in that like what's define is political
politically correct keeps changing while
mark Loftus sounds a bit conservative
sally Eisler at the next table has
volunteered for Democratic candidates
and favored impeaching a polarizing
president we're not together as a
country I don't ever remember time in my
life where I didn't think that we were
all one even if we didn't agree the
voters we met who were sometimes sitting
inches from each other are not likely to
agree in 2020 but it will matter which
of them feels committed enough to show
up let really such great reporting Steve
Inskeep thank you very very much really
fascinating those three Mills I mean I
love being able to talk to regular
people and you find out you can have
conversations with folks about how they
feel and it'd still be respectful it's
just sad when it all comes down to and
you look at Washington it doesn't feel
that way okay they should have three
meals when you cease talking respectful
as you said you know it does move away
from what we sometimes think which is
that everybody's yelling and screaming
it's not really like that when you talk
about food
you